Hôm qua tình hà Nam vừa chết phá uống trong các phở tưu thụ tại sản hỏa độc liên tình
trên ra tay tại các khu dù liệt lệ hội lớn như chủ tâm chúc hả Nam, bài điến, mình và các sân bận động.
Lực lượng chức năng đã bắt sử bẩy đối tượng thu dữ 3-6 mở chính định thoại dí động,
hai ôt tên mặt và nhiều tay sản khác với tổng giả trị hàng tì động.
Các đối tượng khai nhận phần tổng gió phai trò, cạnh dưới, chủ cấp tổ tán và tự tại sản.
Dí hưởng tại chủ tâm chúc phong hai ngày gần để nhất, ngày mấy bầy và mấy tám tháng năm,
nhóm này đã trộ 1 mấy lâm định thoại của người dân và phật tự tìm bãi,
một số nạn nhân sau khi chình báo đã đợi khổ chợi nhận lại tay sản.
Huyện vụ việc đăng được mở giọc điều tra, các quan tình hà Nam cũng thông báo đử dế nóm để tất cả những chình báo,
khổ chợi nhân dân, tìm lại tay sản bị mắt.